well the Dark Knight Rises teaser
trailers out it was on Harry Potter so
now I talk about it and so on the Dark
Knight Rises trailer you sit down it
comes on you're like oh the old footage
and dialogue from the old movies
fast-forward a little bit you get to
what we want to see which is new footage
of the movie and you see Jim Gordon in a
hospital bed and the guy looks like [ __ ]
I don't know he's right he looks like
he's dying so we either took up smoking
or he forgot the safety word in an S&M
Knight with Catwoman probably hopes it's
that second one but in reality Bane
probably beat the living piss out of him
you can barely understand what he's
saying he's like I don't want the guy to
die but it's possible he can't the rules
of the conclusion of a trilogy before
they reboot it and it all doesn't matter
not gonna lie if that dude punched me in
the face I'd probably get a bloody nose
while I'm in a hospital bed I like
basically paraphrasing he's like we were
in this together we had a good thing
going then you went away and this new
evil has risen and you see a dude
working out and climbing out of a hole
at first when I saw the guy doing
push-ups I was like ah there's Bruce
Wayne but I'm like oh might be Bruce
Wayne in flashbacks when he was in lis
know like that Cambodian prison or
whatever wherever it was and I like the
line when Gordon's like The Dark Knight
must come back or something like that
and here Batman reply what if he doesn't
exist anymore and I like that it shows
when you're out of the game for long
enough which apparently he has been you
forget how to do it then you see a
blurry image for a second which comes
into focus its bane to me he kind of
looks like Psycho Mantis from Metal Gear
Solid but all in all I think Bane looks
cool a lot of people are giving hate
because a white guy's playing a Spanish
guy what but ultimately in the whole
Cuban Missile thing in x-men first class
none of those Russian guys were actually
Russian there that is and then the
camera goes up and the building to start
crumbling you see the bat symbol which
is pretty much just like the poster and
then the title The Dark Knight Rises
comes on the screen I think you have
this crazy awesome creepy chanting and
then for me this is the coolest part of
the trailer Batman looks up he looks
like he's just not ready for the fight
that he's in and then the gun show bang
is walking towards Batman you only see
his shoulder his arm like half his upper
body but he looks enormous not gonna lie
he looks a lot bigger than he did in the
poster which makes me think maybe they
are doing the venom thing you never know
what these Nolan Batman some people are
gonna be like yeah I doubt he's doing
the venom thing it's Bane but you know
in that case the Joker should have had
his face bleach but he didn't it was all
Payne makeup all I know is movie trailer
Bane looks a lot bigger than teaser
picture Bane maybe Tom Hardy started
taking steroids after the teaser picture
was taken
I like the trailer for what it is and
that's a teaser trailer for a movie that
come out for a year we've seen more in
this trailer than we saw in the Dark
Knight trailer that came out a year
before the movie oh that was it showed
some beams of light coming out from
behind a bat symbol and it gets stronger
in the bat symbol crumbles away and use
here dialog like I need the mob wouldn't
go down without a fight this is
different don't expect you were wearing
off keypads first son in you a madam and
it turned to a man who wasn't wearing a
key badge this shows a little bit more
than that so I like that all in all you
walk away and you're like I wish it
showed more but then you just think
about it for a while and you're like
that's cool it's on my mind did you see
the trailer what did you think about it
what are your theories for the movie
comment below let me know if saw things
got to be going through your head I'm
just saying and if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more